okay now let's talk going check last 80s
live will be at the Virgin hotels Friday
night and headlining this totally
tubular show will be Wang Chung yeah
that's now we're in my generation I like
it just like I need to do this after
that JC spoke with Nick Feldman and Jack
Hughes from the iconic 80s band
[Music]
Wang Chung welcome to the show I gotta
tell you guys when we first found out
that we were doing an interview with
Wang Chung we're back in the office and
everyone in the office started geeking
out on the fact that Wang Chung is on
Las Vegas now how does that feel after
all these decades your fans are still so
passionate about you guys
you know it's for a couple of old guys
it's pretty great yeah
well I I love I love you guys I love 80s
music I work at a radio station but all
these years have gone by and I I'll be
honest I don't know what is the meaning
of Wang Chung what does it mean to Wang
Chung
reading this book about this uh German
electronic composer called Carl Hyde
stockhausen and there was a little
footnote in in this rather academic book
that he was reading about this thing
called Wang Zhang which means
perfect like perfect pitch in Chinese
music so I think an appeal to Jack's
sense of fun and mine too
[Music]
that's all there's so many hit songs and
one of the biggest ones and one of my
favorites Dance Hall Days that song
comes on the radio I still turn the song
up it's not a wallpaper song it is it's
a hit song after all these decades later
is it that did Paul McCartney have
something to do when you guys were
recording the song do what do you guys
borrow his guitar or something or is
that like some weird rock and roll urban
legend yeah that just happened no did it
so I'm a left-handed bass player and we
were recording in uh Abbey Road Studios
and the bass wasn't sounding quite right
my particular base so the engineer says
I think I can find you another one so
we're so sitting in the control room and
suddenly this guy walks in uh holding a
Yamaha base a left-handed base and he's
said to use from the base rental company
and then he looked at it
one of your songs fire in this Twilight
featured in um The Breakfast Club
[Music]
[Applause]
songs are featured in so many like so
many movies in TV shows Breaking Bad The
Walking Dead Cobra Kai this is a Sex in
the City did you ever turn down a show
where movie someone came to you and said
hey we want to use this song in our show
and you're like no not gonna happen
no
there was some kind of I think really
wanted to substitute something like
everybody eat meat tonight or something
wasn't everybody at fun tonight using an
ABC promo back in the 80s yes yeah it
was it was yeah if they re-recorded it
and changed the words and and uh I think
you still find it on YouTube
[Applause]
[Music]
and you guys are just too sweet thank
you so much for joining us and we're
looking forward to this show on Friday
night
come to Vegas it's a great City and I'm
really looking forward to that show it's
going to be a blast
so fun you can check out Wang Chung and
other artists tomorrow at six for a
totally awesome night of 80s music at
the theater at virgin hotels for tickets
just go to axs.com I'm looking at the
lineup there cool